the crisis has not yet peaked in Italy
but in Lombardy frontline healthcare is
already on its knees the laundry room of
this hospital is being used to treat
patients staff working 18-hour shifts
now treating their own colleagues to a
surgeon in Bergamo updated us on the
desperate situation and what would we
say to your colleagues in Europe
[Music]
patients strong enough to travel from
Lombardy are being brought by helicopter
to other areas of the country further
south though there's already strained to
this doctor shouting to patients in
isolation to keep their distance from
each other in just 10 days this hospital
in Rome has been turned into a kovat 19
facility with a hundred and eighty beds
but if the same crisis levels reach here
it would fill in a day
I think lockdown would be extended I
think it would be the safest option I'm
not totally criticizing the UK strategy
because starting from a very different
starting point we need to hope that that
strategy will be successful
Italy's frontline doctors are known for
their brilliance but barely coping we're
thinking of you their European neighbors
though have the benefit of their
warnings satin Lockwood Sky newsroom